étranger
[Musique]
euh aucun responsable du bureau des États-Unis n'est
contacté, je viens juste de regarder la
télévision et ils s'excusent pour nous ou notre
famille juste comme ça personne n'est en
contact avec moi
[Musique]
tout d'abord
je euh heureux pour cette nouvelle que l'Amérique
accepter leur erreur,
ils se noient attachés dans ma famille
après cette seconde, je veux euh pour vous
dire que chaque erreur pour laquelle il devrait
payer une indemnisation
et la seconde
qu'ils devraient transférer notre famille dans un
pays sûr qu'une personne faisant cette
action qu'ils  devrait le
punir par la loi du tribunal des États-Unis